It’s said that every young girl dreams of
one day becoming a Disney Princess.
For most people, this idea remains nothing
but a dream but for a select few actresses
it may actually become a reality when they
are given the chance to play Disney princesses
in real life.
With Disney making live adaptations of more
and more of their best stories, it looks like
there will be more opportunities on the rise
for actresses to land Disney princess roles.
But, as it turns out, not every actress is
interested in playing a princess and for this
video we are taking a look at some who said
no.
Here is our list of 10 Actors Who Refused
Disney Princess Roles.
Enjoy this video and be sure to hit the subscribe
button for more awesome Screen Rant content
every single day!
Emma Watson – Cinderella
The whole world is excitedly waiting to see
Emma Watson as Disney Princess, Belle, in
the 2017 live adaption of Beauty and The Beast
as the actress seems like the absolute perfect
casting decision.
The world almost got to see Watson as a Disney
princess a few years earlier though as she
was actually first offered the role of Cinderella
in the 2015 film.
Watson turned down the part, saying she wanted
to wait for the right princess role – and
it looks like Belle is it.
On top of turning down Cinderella, Emma Watson
also actually turned down the lead role in
2016’s musical hit La La Land.
That movie has done amazingly well, so we
hope that Watson isn’t regretting her decision.
Elle Fanning – The Little Mermaid (Ariel)
Get ready to see a lot of Elle Fanning in
the near future, as the actress will be showing
up in about eight movies between 2017 and
2018.
One movie that Fanning won’t be showing
up in, however, is the live adaptation of
The Little Mermaid.
Fanning was originally in talks to the play
the lead role of Ariel but decided to turn
it down in favor of playing Sleeping Beauty
in the 2014 film, Maleficent.
This was probably a good choice as the movie
came out much sooner and has helped her launch
her career to a much higher level.
Beyoncé – Tiana in The Princess and The
Frog
Disney made headlines in 2009 when they finally
brought the world their first African American
Disney princess with Tiana in The Princess
and The Frog.
The movie is a lot of fun, and Anika Noni
Rose did a great job voicing Tiana and bringing
a great personality to the character.
Rose wasn’t the directors first choice for
the role, however, as the filmmakers had originally
offered the part to Beyoncé Knowles.
Beyoncé turned the part down because she
wanted to focus on her music and she wasn’t
particularly interested in the script.
Yoncé is doing pretty damn well for herself
these days, so we don’t think she regrets
the decision too much.
Reese Witherspoon – Brave (Merida)
Reese Witherspoon has long been considered
one of Hollywood’s true sweethearts so it
is no surprise that she was offered a role
as a Disney princess.
When Disney was getting set to make the 2012
movie Brave, they had their hopes set on Witherspoon
to play the lead role, Merida.
The actress was game for the part but things
started to go off the rails when she began
to really struggle with the Scottish accent
necessary for the part.
Eventually, the accent became too much for
Reese Witherspoon to handle, and she had to
let the part go, leaving it instead for the
lesser-known actress Kelly Macdonald.
Kristen Stewart – Snow White
Kristen Stewart became one of the most recognizable
stars in the world when she was cast as Bella
Swan in the infamous Twilight Saga, but since
those movies have ended she hasn’t been
able to find the same level of success.
Her biggest role came when she was cast as
Snow White in the 2012’s Snow White and
The Huntsmen.
Although the movie made a lot of movie, it
was not a critical hit and Stewart decided
to refuse the offer to reprise her role in
the 2016 sequel.
It may be every girls dream to play a princess
but we have to hand it to Stewart for getting
out ahead on this one as the sequel currently
sits at a 17% rating on rotten tomatoes.
Margot Robbie – Cinderella
The Australian actress has had no problem
landing major movie roles lately with recent
great performances in hits like Suicide Squad
and The Wolf Of Wall Street.
When Disney starting planning their 2015 live
action adaption of Cinderella, it’s no surprise
that Robbie was one of the actresses at the
top of their list.
Margot Robbie made it to the final stage of
auditions and it is undisclosed whether she
ending up turning down the role or if the
filmmakers decided to go in another direction.
In the end, the role went to Lily James and
the movie was met with moderate success.
All in all, it’s probably better that Margot
Robbie held off on this one and we wouldn’t
be shocked to see her as another Disney princess
in the coming years.
Jennifer Aniston – Giselle (Enchanted)
Before Amy Adams was starring in Oscar movies
every single year, the actress was singing
through the streets as the princess Giselle
in the 2007 Disney musical, Enchanted.
Adams was great in the role, but it turns
out she wasn’t the filmmakers first choice.
Apparently, the role was first offered to
Jennifer Aniston but she refused the part.
While this may seem like a weird casting choice
now, you have to remember that Aniston was
fresh off of the hit series, Friends, and
one of the most sought after actresses around.
Fast forward ten years and Amy Adams is turning
out hit after hit, while Aniston has become
a veteran of the Rom-Com genre.
Jodi Foster – Princess Leia
Ever since Disney got control of the Star
Wars franchise, fans have been campaigning
for Princess Leia to be inducted as one of
the official Disney princesses.
The late Carrie Fisher is iconic in the role
and it’s really hard to imagine anyone else
playing the part but it’s a little known
fact that she actually wasn’t the first
choice.
The role of Princess Leia was first offered
to Jodie Foster who was an up and coming star
back in those days and at the age of 14 would
have been a much younger version of the character.
Foster had to turn the role down due to scheduling
conflicts and we have to think it was fate
as it really is hard to imagine anyone but
Fisher as Princess Leia.
Shiloh Jolie-Pitt
When you are the daughter of Brad Pitt and
Angelina Jolie it’s really only a matter
of time before you start getting offered movie
roles.
It would be most kids dream to play at Disney
princess before they turn ten but it turns
out that Shiloh, the eldest Jolie-Pitt daughter,
actually turned down the role of young Aurora
in her mother’s film, Maleficent.
Shiloh said that she would have been more
interested in playing her mother’s role,
but she will probably have to wait a while
for that one.
Luckily for Angelina Jolie, she didn’t have
to look far for a second choice, as she actually
cast her younger daughter, Vivienne, as the
young version of sleeping beauty.
Chloe Grace Moretz – The Little Mermaid
(Ariel)
Although she is yet to turn 20, Chloe Grace
Moretz has already been a huge Hollywood star
for years now.
From The Amityville Horror, to Kick-Ass to
Neighbors 2, Moretz has done a lot of work
for someone her age.
When the live adaptation of Disney’s The
Little Mermaid was announced, the filmmakers
had Chloe Grace Moretz at the top of their
list to play Ariel, and originally the actress
was on board.
Then, last years, Chloe decided that she wanted
to take a break from acting for a bit and
decided to back out of the Disney princess
role.
The actress is now looking to take on more
challenging roles as she tries to break away
from her past as a child star and launch a
career as a serious Hollywood actress.
So there you have it, there is our list of
10 actors who refused Disney Princess movie
roles.
What did you think of our list?
Which one of these casting would you like
to have seen?
Let us know your thoughts in the comments
section below and be sure to subscribe to
our channel for more fun videos – like this
one!